you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the director
of the demos think tank polly mckenzie
and the telegraph's assistant comment
editor madeline grant they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now
with the headline boris as wine time
fridays the mirror breaks the news
that
end of week drinking sessions were a
regular feature at downing street during
lockdown
perhaps fittingly a cabinet minister
speaking anonymously to the telegraph
describes the prime minister as being in
the last chance saloon
the ft describes mr johnson's future as
hanging by a thread
the eye reports that the chancellor
rishi sunak and the foreign secretary
liz truss are poised to launch
conservative leadership bids
the telegraph suggests the prime
minister will aim to stage a political
comeback by scrapping plan b coveted
restrictions
the express comes to the defense of the
queen over allegations two parties were
held at number 10 the night before
prince philip's funeral
the sun has word of boris johnson's
apology to the queen over the matter
as well as that angle the guardian
focuses on the anger the matter has
caused at tory grassroots
level the star pleads
will
thef
bozo's flunkies caught having a lockdown
party please turn out the lights will
the last of bozo's flunkies caught
having a lockdown party please turn out
the lights
and the mail carries images of sakia
stammer with what appears to be a bottle
of beer in his hand which the paper
alleges were taken at a work party in
april last year a labor spokesperson has
insisted sakir was working in the office
of a fellow mp and had paused for dinner
and by scanning the qr code on your
screen right now you can check out the
front pages of tomorrow's newspapers as
they come in
and we're joined tonight by polly
mckenzie and madeline grant welcome to
you both good evening let's start with
the mirror uh and that headline that um
we've been running this this this
evening boris's wine time fridays uh
suggesting something of a culture within
westminster polly
well this is another story by pepper
at the mirror who has kind of led the
way on so many of these party gate
scandals
in some way i think this is the
probably the smallest of the stories
in that uh informally having a glass of
wine at your desk is completely
different kind of scale than some of the
bigger parties in the garden that we've
heard about and yet i think it's really
fascinating the the outrage that that
this is triggered and the fact that it's
coming out as another scandal tells you
quite a lot about what's going on in
downing street at the moment and i think
the public mood about this
if it was just a question of some people
in downing street have a glass of wine
at the end of the week uh where they're
working very hard often quite late even
on a friday night uh bit like us for
example i i don't think that's massively
controversial
but
the reality is that
this was doing it during a pandemic
where
every other workplace in the land
including workplaces where people were
still having to go into work schools or
hospitals
or distribution facilities they were
changing their behavior common rooms
were closed staff rooms were closed and
what's extraordinary about these
revelations is that none of the behavior
which you might think was kind of fine
in normal times changed in number 10 the
very source of those rules and again
just final thought is the reality is for
staff in number 10 at the moment who are
thinking
is boris johnson going to survive
what's the future for my job should i
leak more information what are my
tactics here again it's clear that the
incentives to put more information are
out are there because you know more and
more information is getting to
journalists uh mad the the article um
points to the fact that the prime
minister uh regularly popped in uh to
see workers and actually was encouraging
them to to let off steam
yeah
exactly and i think
that and also what polly just said it
really taps into i found the story
particularly annoying even though in
itself it's perhaps not the biggest
example um because if you know putting
aside the hypocrisy for one second and
there's plenty of hypocrisy to go around
and the thing that really got me is that
clearly bruising after work with people
that you've been spending the whole day
with carries very little health risk
you've already been working alongside
them the prime minister knew this he
went in and encouraged them to do it the
people in downing street knew this
perfectly well and they acted
accordingly but they lacked sufficient
respect for the public to let them also
make that same calculation um the rules
were far more rigorous than clearly they
thought was rational because their
rational behavior
shows that they
shows what they thought of things um you
know the ability to exercise your
judgment as a rational adult um so it's
clear that
many of these rules that were imposed on
us were illogical and stupid um and also
that the people making them knew this um
perfectly well and and kept imposing
them anyway so there was a kind of super
patronizing element of this story that
that gets me
i guess above and beyond the kind of
material facts of of the drinking itself
yes and the other revelation tonight as
uh detailed on the front page of the
star is the
former covid task force head admitting
that that she too attended a uh
rule-breaking party a leaving party for
herself polly
uh i mean
one of boris johnson's defenses at prime
minister's questions this week was that
when he went to this gathering in the
garden he didn't really know it was a
party he thought it was a work event
didn't really couldn't possibly
understand exactly the details of the
rules or the guidance
sort of sort of i have like a
microscopic quantity of sympathy for
that opinion but only microscopic
because you know he is the prime
minister um he ought really to pay
attention but nevertheless he's not
really a details guy by contrast the
head of the covid task force in number
10 was the person literally running the
team
typing out these regulations deciding
the guidance and coordinating that and
yet she herself either didn't understand
the regulations didn't understand what
the rules said or to madeleine's point
didn't really care and you know some
people will believe that madeleine's
right and actually the rules were too
draconian others will believe that the
rules were fine and they were
appropriate at a time when our knowledge
was was less about about this disease
perfectly rational people will have both
of those positions what's not rational
is to have both of those positions at
the same time you cannot believe that
they were the right rules and that the
people setting them shouldn't have to
stick with them uh and now it is the um
fight back against all of these uh
revelations and the telegraph suggesting
that the prime minister will um
scrap plan b and get rid of further
restrictions as a means of getting
people back on side uh is that going to
work madeline
i mean it will take a lot a lot to get
people back on side but i suppose as
part of a kind of initial rehabilitation
strategy ditching covert regulations is
a good place to start ditching covered
passports and the work from home
guidance um i think that they could go a
lot further than just what they've been
doing here they could do things like an
amnesty for all the fines and um
erasing some of the criminal records of
people who were actually caught by the
um the covert rules that we now know
that the people in charge were breaking
all the time um and you know i think it
is a an attempt to connect with the
grassroots because there have been some
and also the rest of the party there
have been some very powerful
interventions from people like lord
frost um calling for the party to kind
of
reclaim its identity as the the party of
freedom and enterprise um and obviously
it's been very much overlooked in you
know all the completely justified fury
about the number at number 10 parties
but i think what this party sorry what
this story um not a party sadly um
slightly alludes to is that you know the
removal of restrictions around this time
could have been a massive victory for
the prime minister you know back in
december every man and his dog was
clamoring seemingly for more
restrictions um everyone from you know
stage the labour party and some of the
modeling and the predictions that coming
out of places like imperial and warwick
university were you know truly
apocalyptic um and the the cabinet quite
sensibly it now appears decided to um go
against this wall of criticism to to
open up and were it not for the absolute
terrible owned goals and the leakings
and um the terrible uh calamity for the
number 10 comms machine
the period now i think would be a time
where people a lot of people taking
stock and um you know this could have
been a period in which you know would
have come across like a a real victory
uh for the prime minister but um you
know this is i think an underappreciated
way in which um the last couple of weeks
have been uh disastrous for number 10.
the daily express is uh suggesting that
the prime minister should uh personally
apologize to the queen that's over the
party on the eve of prince philip's
funeral polly
yeah i think it's really quite
significant that the express who over
the course of this week have
um really backed boris and said you know
don't don't let brexit slip away because
of this you know let's let's get him
through this um and uh just yesterday
ran an article um saying that
actually it was all a remainer
conspiracy all of this uh hating on
boris
for the express to then turn on him in
defense of her majesty the queen
and suggest that his uh the apology
which was conveyed to her today was
insufficient and he should go and grovel
in person
from a safe distance whilst wearing a
mask uh perhaps um is really quite
significant i mean i happen to agree
with the express that to have to have
behaved in such a way
is uh is unacceptable i'm not sure an
apology um gets very far you know the
reality is that for a prime minister to
be taken seriously by uh our queen who
has seen some really extraordinary prime
ministers in her time i i think what you
need to do is somehow go back in time
and not have done this not have led a a
party culture in number 10 through one
of the greatest uh crises of our era
madeleine just a few seconds for you to
contribute to that
yeah absolutely i mean i think that
the queen the way that the queen has has
handled everything throughout the
pandemic and the sacrifices that she has
made um just form such a kind of jarring
jarring and um awkward contrast with the
the kind of self-serving and duplicitous
behavior that we've seen from number 10
and the ability to you know simply be
straight with people even when bad
things that uh come out into the public
eye let's have a look at the mail and
this
article focusing on sakir stama who's
obviously been very critical of boris
johnson the prime minister and uh
parties that he he may have attended in
the downing street garden but didn't
wasn't sure whether it was a party or
not uh they're accusing sakir starma of
hypocrisy because he's photographed here
having a drink during lockdown with with
colleagues this is from april 2021.
polly
well what's interesting is you know
normally the papers don't like to run
each other's stories but this is a
photograph that first ran in the sun in
may 2021 so relatively soon after
you know it's clear what the mail is
doing here though you know
kierstama has answered these allegations
as is completely appropriate you know
and it does appear that he indeed is
drinking
uh in the office with some of his
colleagues but it wasn't a massive blow
up scandal in the way that these series
of what are we on now 17 uh possible
parties that happened in the downing
street kind of surrounding estate it
didn't blow up when it was in the sun in
may it's clear it you know i'm not quite
sure why what the mail is doing they're
trying to you know spread the hatred
really so that it's about all
politicians i i think you know
it's it's not actually news it's a
tactic um and
it's a pretty transparent one
madeleine do you think this the story
has any legs at all do you think people
will address it with with fresh eyes
well i think it's a fair point to make
because um labour have used exactly the
same excuse i'm not saying that it's
exactly the same magnitude i think what
the government did was far worse not
least because they they were more
involved in actually making the rules uh
but labour used the same excuse that the
government did that these were
work-related drinks uh hence the call of
hypocrisy and i mean i think i think
that is fair because i've seen a lot in
the last few days the labour party have
been uh busily pointing out the the
barbarity of the rules and saying you
know how could the government be so
hypocritical and fair enough the rules
were completely barbaric but labour also
voted come through and very often called
for harsher rules and longer lockdowns
than even the government were doing so i
do find the
the recent sort of damn scene conversion
to the inhumanity of lockdown um
actually quite hypocritical and quite
hard to buy into
polly we just got time to go to the
guardian and the djokovic drama
continues on his second appeal uh this
evening
this is just endlessly fascinating this
story because it has flipped a whole
bunch of you know guardian easters who
are now in favor of very strict border
controls to punish djokovic for not
having a vaccine meanwhile we've had you
know nigel farage uh and others uh in
favor of allowing anyone who wants to go
to australia seemingly to go to
australia and suddenly being opposed to
strict border controls that novak
djokovic has a last-ditch appeal uh but
if he loses that he will be uh deported
um and um that may even result in a ban
on returning to australia for a number
of years uh and madeline very quickly
one of the reasons the government is
saying that um he should be deported is
because they believe his presence could
um and excite anti-vaxxers
well yeah that's a great example of how
the australian government's position is
shifting depending on what's expedient
because the initial justification was
about visa requirements and then they
got the wrong answer from the federal
court so they had to reposition it as an
anti-vaxx thing and i think they have a
real problem on their hands because if
djokovic does play on monday there will
be a massive backlash from the
australian citizens who are
overwhelmingly opposed to him but if he
doesn't that will also be caused that an
unbalanced draw you know of unfairness
and so on so i think it'll be very
interesting to see what happens because
i think in a way
they're following public opinion very
much but they've also created something
of a rod for their own backs here yeah
indeed it will thank you both good to
see